welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and reed richards of the fantastic
four was supposed to survive dr strange
at the multiverse of madness according
to screenwriter michael waldron who
confirmed to empire magazine this week
that the original plan was for an
alternate post-credits scene that would
have left the mcu multiverse in a very
different place and the night janitor of
the 838 baxter building with a much
easier night and this video is brought
to you by squarespace the all-in-one
platform for building your brand more on
them later in a recent interview with
empire waldron talked about his original
ending for doctor strange and the
multiverse madness he said quote in my
very first draft i wrote a tag just for
the hell of it of the events of the
movie being recorded and reviewed by
somebody in the baxter building and a
stretchy hand coming out of frame to run
it back reed is probably my favorite
marvel comics character so i was always
gunning to get him in here somewhere in
the weeks and months after multiverse of
madness came out we have been learning
more and more about the various versions
of this film from the earlier version
from director scott derrickson and
writer c robert cargill to the rewrite
overseen by new director sam raimi and
writer michael waldron in an interview
with sci-fi walter actually confirmed
that the entire illuminati sequence
entered the picture with his first draft
waldron said he outlined a version
without the illuminati but then as he
was writing that out he wanted to go off
the rails make his first draft a wilder
more drunk version of itself and here
was when he added the illuminati
massacre and walter said he was
completely surprised how receptive
everyone was to this and how the final
verse of the movie included this wild
sequence in it in this interview he went
on to say his original lineup was
actually close to this final one saying
he thought here's the craziest version
there's no way we'll actually get to do
this but by the end they actually were
since much of waltran's dialogue about
the multiverse and incursion seemed
inspired directly by what reed richards
says in the 2015 john hickman comics
that kicks off the time running out
storyline on the road to secret wars
it's safe to assume that reed richards
was really at the top of his illuminati
lineup in his first draft the same draft
that had this alternate post-credits
scene written out so therefore the
original plan was for the scarlet witch
to murder reed richards but then for
reed to have survived that and to have
returned in the post-credits scene but
how the hell could reed richard survive
what scarlet witch did to him just as a
reminder so when the comics read
richards it's actually meant to be near
indestructible secret invasion begins
with the squirrel posing as hank pym
blasting reed with the molecular
destabilizer that dematerializes reed's
anatomy but reed survives it world war
hulk features hulk beating reed to a
flattened bruised form but hulk doesn't
actually kill reed there he just kind of
overwhelms and paralyzes him now the
scarlet witch is meant to be the most
powerful being in the mcu and if she can
kill blackvul one would think she could
kill reed richards the unraveling of his
body like string cheese the pain reed
endures the way she pops his head like a
pinata is as visceral a death as the mcu
can really give us and for good measure
let's show it again
still visually this isn't too different
from the molecular destabilization that
reed undergoes in secret invasion and as
i said reed does go on to survive that
his body gets stretched out and tortured
by the scrolls as they try to figure out
how his physiology works until he gets
freed by abigail brand and he resumes
coming up with a way to distinguish
between humans and scroll imposters fun
fact we should bring up here one of reed
richard's few weaknesses in the comics
was revealed in recent years to be
besides his over-curious intellect and
ego tickling but i wouldn't describe
wanda twisting his limbs to be a tickle
fight waldron's confirmation here
suggests that reed's lifeless ribbony
form on the floor of the baxter
foundation could have still been alive
i'm not dead yeah he says he's not dead
yes he is i'm not i don't know if you've
gotten news yet but this whole internet
thing looks like it's here to stay
hope so that means if you're trying to
get that new business of yours up and
running you're gonna need a website so
you're gonna need squarespace
squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful online presence for
that new business you don't want your
website looking like something that was
hard coded into html back in 1998 you
want it looking and functioning like the
cream of the 2022 crop and squarespace
can help you do just that squarespace
has a bunch of great features to help
your business be successful you can
present members only gated content
create email campaigns or add online
booking for appointments or sessions all
from the squarespace interface for me my
favorite aspect is the analytics section
that's where squarespace makes it easy
to dig into what's working what's not
and figure out what levers you can pull
to make your business even more
successful head to squarespace.com for a
free trial and when you're ready to
launch go to squarespace.com new
rockstars to save 10 off your first
purchase of a website or a domain that's
squarespace.com new rockstars for 10 off
your first purchase of website or a
domain while the corpses of blackbolton
captain carter aren't really lingered on
after their deaths the stretched out
pieces of reed's corpse remain strewn
across the floor in various shots as the
scarlet witch fights the other members
of the illuminati so in this post-credit
scene as described reed recovered well
enough to play back the events of the
movie i assume not the full events of
the movie because how would the baxter
foundation have according to that no
he's probably referring to the ultron
century security footage to figure out
exactly what went down there perhaps to
learn more about the status of the wanda
max moth in universe 838 whose body was
hijacked by the scarlet witch dream
walking into her perhaps he was seeking
to understand whether his universe's
wanda is to blame for the massacre or if
she still shows any signs of possession
you gotta imagine reed richards after he
told this threat about his wife sue
storm and his children franklin and
valeria richards maybe he's watching the
footage back to see if he has any reason
to worry about his family i have
children of my own i understand your
pain
is their mother still alive
yes good there will be someone left to
raise them reid surviving is actually
pretty good news for the fate of that
innocent possessed 838 wanda because now
there is a living witness to explain to
the loved ones of the other members of
the illuminati that the one who killed
those people wasn't really to blame like
i don't really know if 838 mordo ever
made it out of that trench or if he did
he would be that sympathetic to that
wanda he wasn't really in the room where
all the others were killed though reed
survival sets up reed to be a key
peacekeeper and defense witness to
whatever trial faces this wanda next but
we also must wonder since this was the
838 universe's freaking baxter
foundation building it's supposedly most
secure impenetrable research lab and
fortress fortified by the people who
defeated thanos in this reality what
else could have been kept in this
structure that a recovering reed
richards would play back the security
footage to check on other secret portals
like the one steven strange used to hide
the book of vashanti maybe information
hidden on the servers about other
universes since christine palmer knew
enough to categorize them as 838 and the
others is 616. it just wouldn't surprise
me if the 838 baxter foundation is the
citadel that contains a codex or a
roadmap for the known multiverse and
reed would need to make sure that it
wasn't stolen or destroyed i mean
clearly this read is already something
of an expert in the multiverse it's
likely that the guy already knows that
his familial succession will lead to
nathaniel richards kang the conqueror
and he wants to keep that secret from
getting out or from someone from finding
out and targeting his family to prevent
the kang threat from rising ultimately
this just gives us hope that the john
krasinski variant of reed richards could
still live on in the mcu multiverse
either this 838 universe variant or some
other one as marvel studios moves toward
a fantastic four film and secret wars
it's just inevitable that at some point
the new mcu read will meet his variants
played by other actors including
krasinski and a council of reid's
team-up the way tom hall and peter
parker met his multiversal variants
would you have preferred this sending
slash post-credits scene for doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness do
you want john krasinski's version of the
character to live on in the multiverse
or are you really done with that version
of the character as much as the scarlet
witch was comment down below with your
thoughts and follow me on tick tock
instagram and twitter at avos subscribe
to rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you